this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is diving back
into call of duty vanguard to see if his
firearms are a little less cursed in the
campaign spoilers it still broke him but
maybe not as much this is a fancy
sporting gun this is not a military
issue weapon by any stretch of the
imagination and it makes zero sense for
it to be where it is in the numbers that
it's in make sure to check out our
previous episode on cod vanguard which
truly tested the limits of jonathan's
mind
wow and if there are any other games
guns and mechanics that you guys want to
see jonathan break down let us know in
the comment section below be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
[Music]
the
the garand or the grand if you prefer is
a little bit of a mixed bag the model
overall
looks really good might be the best
looking m1 garand that we've had i'm
open for debate on that one uh it has
the perennial issue of the rear sight
aperture being far too big the smaller
the aperture in theory the more accurate
those iron sights are
forces your eye to be more precise so
this big open aperture
is like even bigger than what you'd see
on a submachine gun it's far too big now
loading and reloading we've got a the
iconic ping which sounds very good
indeed i'm sure that's recorded live
audio curious moment here where we eject
a mostly depleted clip so it turns out
there are two live rounds left but when
the cocking handle is pulled back to
eject that clip what should come out is
a live round because this is a
self-loading rifle and it should have
loaded the next round into the chamber
what should not be coming out is a fired
case which this is you can even see the
the dent on the primer if an empty case
without a dent on the primer came out
you'd be you'd be worrying because that
would mean your bullet was stuck in the
ball somewhere so that's a curious
mistake
oh no
no that's uh that's wrong
right so we've got a version of the
reload here which i assume kicks in when
you have more than half full a more than
half full clip what we're seeing is the
whole nearly full clip only one round
expended being plucked out of the action
it's not how this works he's not
pressing the clip release catch on the
left side of the weapon which you can
actually see from first person view it's
the dark sort of angle immediately below
the elevation adjustment drum in fact
let me grab one on the left side of the
weapon you can see this when the rifle
is uh not when you're not aiming down
sight you can see this big button on the
side that is the clip release button now
it's not that you can't hit that ahead
of time you can with a fully with a
partially or fully loaded clip you can
press that button the action will click
and then when you pull back the cocking
handle out will pop your partially
loaded or even fully loaded clip so we
don't see the player go anywhere near
that button they're not pressing it with
their thumb ahead of time they're not
holding it down while they then pull
back the charging handle which you could
do as well they don't do any of that
they just pull back the charging handle
an empty case comes flying out for some
reason and then they somehow reach in
and pluck out the partially loaded clip
and then slap in a full one doesn't work
like that
you may have noticed a i was going to
say deliberate mistake i don't i don't
think it's well i think it probably is a
deliberate mistake in the sense that um
they don't really care where weapons
appear either chronologically or
geographically because we saw on the
ground there uh studum sgg44 in terms of
time this may well be okay because i'm
guessing we are pacific theater given
the japanese troops what on earth
japanese troops are doing with sgg44s is
another matter i suppose we could invent
some kind of head cannon for
crates of sdgs shipped out by by the
nazis given their situation i very much
doubt that they would have done that if
they wouldn't have done that so
don't know why that's there
[Music]
right
this looks to be pacific again we again
somehow have sturm gervais available
well the first thing i noticed was the
lack of iron sights on this thing it
looks completely wrong without iron
sight and it's a such a bizarre design
decision to do this i assume this
happens when you equip a scope although
the icon on the screen has both which it
would and does in real life here's my uh
as someone in the comments said last
time emotional support stung revere so
when you when you equip the scope on the
side rail you don't magically lose your
iron sights
not an early optic optical sight but an
early combat battlefield infantry
optical sight if this thing breaks or
loses zero you're gonna want your iron
sights so it doesn't make sense on a
tactical or practical level and it
doesn't make sense on a logical level in
terms of these are part of the gun they
don't come off i think this is where um
developers really can benefit from not
necessarily coming to us but coming to a
museum collection or to a private
collection or to movie armors as they
often do and actually getting hands on
themselves because watching the reload
with the with the stormgiver in
particular it's just sort of a light tap
on the magazine catch and out comes the
magazine it's it's a much more of a
physical experience to to get a magazine
off this weapon what we're seeing here
is extrapolation backwards from modern
armalite pattern rifles where you
literally just tap the button the mag
just cleanly drops out and you slap
another one in ergonomics like that took
a long time to develop
something big coming up
so this is the mark ii
bren one of those that has the flip up
adjustable sight on the top of the
receiver at the rear rather than the
old-fashioned drum of the mark one the
the vehicle sequence of course you could
fire a brand from a moving vehicle like
any other firearm you might hit
something the reality of that experience
in the second world war of course was
mounting something like a brand to
a pole type mount jeeps
land rovers the bren carrier vehicles
like that had brands hard mounted to
them so the recoil is not an issue the
movement of the vehicle is much less of
an issue so if you had to fire a brand
from a moving vehicle pick one of those
vehicles rather than whatever this is
i've got a reload here uh done fairly
convincingly sort of overhand grip
pushing the magazine catch with the
thumb you could do it that way but it's
awkward generally of course fired from
the prone position and in theory with a
two-man team so the shooter would use
the heel of his hand and knock the
magazine off and then the assistant
gunner immediately inserts the next
magazine and they carry on firing now if
you're firing it from the shoulder or
from the hip as they certainly did out
in borneo malaya you've got to come up
with a different way of doing it but i
still think palming it off the gun is
probably preferable to trying to like
upside down ak it i wouldn't i wouldn't
fancy that
well i was just about to say there isn't
much to say about the car 98k but
there's something funky going on with
that bayonet now i i approve of bayonets
being in a second world war game they
were an important part of training and
of fighting at the time and they had a
gameplay element as well of course
especially when you have a slow firing
rifle like any bolt action but this
bayonet is mounted at a really jaunty
angle on the side of the gun i can't get
a good enough view to see exactly what's
going on but the bayonet lug on the
connector 8k is a long tenon mounted
directly below the barrel the bayonet
should be mounted below the barrel why
it's off to a side to the side like that
i can only imagine it so that the player
can see the bayonet better from the
perspective that we're at but that's not
how it fits to the rifle and it would be
sub-optimal um for the running through
of one's enemy
come on bowie
nicely nicely modelled view of the gun
from first person uh this is the the
enfield course which is why i've
immediately i'm immediately going to
pick up the the user here i'm not sure
which character this is supposed to be
but palming the bolt
was not a thing
uh british soldiers were taught and i'm
not so sure about other nations so we'll
allow we'll give some allowance in case
this is not the british british
character but anyway it should be finger
and thumb like that and then it pivots
like like a ball and socket joint within
the socket made by your finger and thumb
if that makes sense that allows you to
flick the thing back and forth really
quite quickly depending on your level of
training and experience but we don't see
that here so we can assume that this
person was not trained in the british
army another curious feature the number
four had a a really quite good target
style rear sight that would flip up for
long range fine adjustment with the
wheel on the top this is left folded
down which is fine we're doing combat at
close range for the most part and the
rear battle aperture site that's what
that was there for but this one's been
cut off it's been cut in half it should
be a complete loop it doesn't work as
well with your eye if it's
cut in half yeah i don't know why that's
why that's happened we could put this
down to personal preference of the user
that for whatever reason they like to be
able to have a better field of view at
close range so they cut the top off
their site maybe there's an example of
that somewhere on a real rifle but i've
not seen one
[Music]
so this is the three-line rifle as it's
known in vanguard for anyone that's
confused by that as to why it's not
called mosin or mosin nagant three-line
rifle is the english translation of the
rifle's actual name in russian lines
were a measure of caliber so three line
equates to
effectively 30 caliber 762. now we all
know about the the mosin i'm sure we're
going to we won't reprise any of that
but uh and of course the sniper variant
different scopes available this is the
pe
m or the pe-2 the sort of the longer of
the classic mosin scopes and the reticle
isn't right so this is some sort of a
fine cross hair it should be the two
bars from the side and the pointed post
from underneath here it's a an
historically correct reticle but not for
this scope and therefore not for this
rifle so when you [ __ ] the thing
like most many bolt action rifles a
large part of the board significant part
of the of the bolt assembly stays to the
rear it's the cocking piece or the
striker and in the case of the mosin
that is a big l-shaped piece
the leg of which sits over the top you
can see it in your first person view and
so when you pull the trigger although
you wouldn't be looking at it of course
that should fly forward by a significant
amount we should see that piece of the
gun move
and it doesn't now it's only of concern
for nerds like me that are looking for
it i doubt i didn't even have noticed it
if i was playing the game rather than
critiquing it on a clip but um it's
there so i've mentioned it
it's our old favorite the mp40 and it's
looking pretty good i think there might
still be too much recoil because this
thing really does chug quite slowly and
quite controllably and it's super
buffered in there it's got a telescopic
sprung buffer in it and so i don't think
it should be coming back at our faces as
much as it is i think that's a realistic
period hold for the gun the magazine
while on the mp40 is ribbed for
strength but also as a grasping area
because the receiver is sort of grooved
for the hand to sort of cup it back here
but that's far too close to the firing
hand to be comfortable standard grip for
this thing well if it's a war movie
you'll see or certain games they will
grab the magazine quite low down and
like fire it sideways or something in
this case it looks like quite a
realistic grip grasping the magazine
well so you're not interfering with the
magazine stopping the gun from working
and you can control the gun quite nicely
maybe the thumb over the top might get a
little bit toasty after a while
right well it's nice to see an owen gun
in a game i've grabbed one of ours just
to really to just show you because it's
cool on the uh production guns this is a
rare prototype the back end of the
receiver is that big wedge shape that we
see
there this is a pretty faithful
recreation of the early pattern
production australian owen gun where
they dropped the ball unfortunately and
this although it's a prototype is um the
owen has a weird cocking handle mounted
at the back of the gun but it is always
on the right hand side so the ejection
port is underneath as it would have to
be the magazine mounted on the top
and the cocking handle is on the right
hand side so the whole gun is actually
flipped which is kind of intriguing and
i'm not sure why possibly to do with the
sight rear sight location now when you
shoulder this thing you actually realize
that with your cheek on the buttstock
that puts your right eye directly behind
the right side mounted sight so flipping
the gun which they may well have done
thinking well we can't get the rear
aperture into the center of the player's
screen we'll just flip the gun maybe the
images are the wrong way around well the
images aren't the wrong way around and
this is where actually getting hands on
the real thing is very important guys
well worth doing if you want that extra
touch of detail
because there it is
i can see the sights perfectly
okay the sten gun the whole gun looks
too long could be me i'm not gonna go
and grab a sten and try and like compare
it uh just now but uh my impression
is
the rear sight is wrong so it's cut in
half it should be a
circle you wouldn't go for a u-shaped
notch like that you'd go for the for the
full loop like the simplified sight on
the thompson or the site on all of the
stem guns now they have put they have
filed in a notch at the bottom of the u
so it's almost like a sort of buckhorn
site or so you can use the u for for
rapid acquisition and then the notch for
fine aiming we can surmise perhaps that
this is a field modification carried out
by one of the
carrot main characters that they've cut
it off so you get a more clear field of
view around you while keeping the weapon
in the aim and then they filed a notch
in the bottom
for fine aiming now the problem there is
if your normal aiming your normal sight
picture is tip of the front sight level
with the where it's been cut off and
then your fine aiming is having to drop
that front sight into that fine notch
well you're now shooting into the ground
so i don't think that works um i think
that's just been fudged and is a mistake
empty one o'clock
right not really not a problem with the
gun although the mark vi webley was old
hat and should really be replaced uh by
this point by the number two revolver
essentially a legally different scaled
down webley made by the royal small arms
factory at enfield in
380. that's the the sidearm i'd expect
to see in this situation albeit we are
in the desert i think it's plausible
enough that mark sixes are still around
mid-war that's fine
bit of weirdness here the vast majority
of fire we're seeing here is in double
action mode where um the shooter is just
pulling through on the trigger and it's
cocking and releasing the hammer we'd
probably expect that to be the main mode
in which you would use
um a double action revolver in combat
for an accurate shot at longer range you
might thumb the hammer back to pre-cock
it it's less of a strain on your hand
and finger and therefore more accurate
and i'm pretty sure i just saw that
happen but without the thumb going to
the hammer it just kind of came back of
its own accord and then stopped there
because you can stage a double action
trigger by pulling it back to near the
release point holding it there and then
pulling it the rest of the way but it
didn't look like that's what was
happening it looked like it was
magically cocking itself as i said
before answers on a postcard for that
one
right this feels a little like showing
off but hey i don't it's not my
collection so um i'm gonna show off
anyway the type 100 submachine gun
japanese that's what we're seeing here
and it's just some something different
something exciting and it's nice that
it's there in the game now the reason
for showing you this other than just
bragging rights for um the royal
armouries is that this is the original
pattern from 1940. uh the version seen
here i think was introduced 43 without
checking and it is slightly simplified
mainly in terms of lower quality
manufacture it's not quite last ditch
but it's sort of heading in that
direction this is this is a bit more
nicely made
so there will be differences from this
and the on-screen model the original
1940 version had a much more elaborate
rear sight a bit of a theme with
submachine guns they start out with
elaborate rear sights and they get rid
of them because they're just not
necessary if anyone happens to have
a first pattern
type 100 magazine please send it to us
now that's a bit a bit like asking for a
sample of rocking horse poop because
these are extremely rare even these
which are the later pattern of type 100
mag which fits our later pattern type
100 doesn't fit this now can you imagine
playing a first person shooter game
where you pick up ammunition and you go
and it won't go in well that is a
theoretical prospect for a japanese
soldier in the second world war although
i'm sure they have logistical ways to
prevent that from happening anyway a
really important gun and i'm very
pleased that we have one
yeah this one's a real head scratcher so
like everybody else i saw the uh the
preview demo footage ten minutes
whatever it was of the early early
campaign where
uh lady death the fictional version of
um
uh ludmila pablochenko is john
mcclaining her way through a manchester
through it through a you know fancy
house and there's a german officer i
think it was
with this becca shotgun now this is a
gucci very unusual rotary drum
revolver type shotgun as you can see and
it's modeled beautifully and it works as
i believe it does work we don't have one
in the collection they're that rare i
think only 100 or so were ever made and
in that context i thought oh okay that's
a cool bit of forgotten weapon in the
campaign in a specific scene she'll take
that from this german officer who's
brought it from home because he's
wealthy kill him with it she'll use it
until she gets to her fights her way to
a sniper rifle and that's as much as
we'll see of it and then they'll put it
in multiplayer but from all the footage
i've just been shown
it's bleeding everywhere
it's in all theaters of the war this is
a fancy sporting gun this is not a
military issue weapon by any stretch of
the imagination and it makes zero sense
for it to be where it is in the numbers
that it's in enough said about that one
i think
if you'd like to support the work that
we do here at the royal armouries in the
uk we have links in the description as
always for donation our membership
scheme i do a series over on our own
channel looking in a little bit more
depth at some historic firearms from the
collection so feel free to check that
out as well and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you